three states still moving forward
forward with today's primaries despite
the cv 19 concerns including the big
state of florida here to weigh in is
Florida's GOP Senator Marco Rubio good
morning to you senator good morning good
morning
so what is your opinion of that do you
think Florida should still continue to
have the primary well it's not I don't
think it's fair for me to pass judgment
on it because I wasn't in those meetings
with the governor and the Florida health
authorities who reviewed it all looked
at the disruption it would create and
made that decision as you heard in that
clip that just played a moment ago the
governor was advised by the leading
health authorities that he relies on
that they thought that activity could go
on without opposing the public health
threat and so you know absent contrary
information I'm not going to question
the decision that they've made them at
this point it's happening and I don't
want to be I don't want to be out there
discouraging people from from voting at
this point all right so let's talk about
the relief bills that are working their
way in your lap today and then Stephen
Newton will introduce a third relief
bill coming your way from what you've
seen what stands out that you like and
don't like well first of all let me just
say this we are not living in ordinary
times okay these are not ordinary times
this is not a bunch of businesses who
made a bad decision and now we're
looking for the government to help them
out this is a virus that threatens our
economy because in order to prevent this
virus from killing a lot of people we
have to force people or ask people to
stay home and not go to businesses and
the result is people are going to lose
their jobs
businesses are going to close and we're
gonna have to do something to buffer
that absolutely and so and so that's the
way I would judge everything that we're
talking about what the House passed is
not perfect but I think the price of
inaction at this point is way too high
in the meantime whatever's wrong with
that bill we will look to fix in a bill
that will start here in the Senate that
we need to pass very quickly and that I
think will be focused on number one
you're getting allowing Airlines to
continue to operate because if we shut
down the airlines we're gonna have not a
very different country we're not gonna
be able to move people around important
trips that need to happen for public
healthy and for national security and so
forth and the second is we need to get
funds we need to get liquidity into the
hands of small businesses who are not
going to be able to meet payroll as
required under the paid leave
requirements of the House bill and are
going to struggle to be around for six
eight twelve weeks from now when
everything sort of settles down a little
bit and so that's the part that we're
focused on we've got a pretty good
outline that's bipartisan obviously we
need to hear from more of our colleagues
but that's the piece I'm gonna focus on
and we need to move on that very very
fast you just time to spare senator you
just used a word we don't hear much
these days from Washington and that is
bipartisan it seems like lawmakers on
both sides of the aisle realize the
gravity of this particular global
pandemic and they're pulling out as many
stops as is possible by Washington
standards you know most of the things we
do around here despite the fact that
we're given to hyperbole the vast
majority of things we do here on a daily
basis are not going to be remembered in
the long view of history
maybe not even a year from now this is
going to be written about a hundred
years from now this is a global event
that will fundamentally change the
structure of the world political order
the world economic order for a
generation this is a huge event that's
happening and for our country it's very
impactful that makes partisan bickering
and potshots at this point trivial we
will have time later on in the future to
examine all the decisions that were made
and to figure out who made mistakes so
we can prevent it from happening again
in people will be held to account now is
not that time now is the time to act to
keep this from being worse than it needs
to be and and we can't do that if we
spend all our time taking political
potshots or
arguing over ideological purity and
thing is could this be one of the last
times you guys get together in this era
of social distancing is it safe for the
centers to be packed into a chamber how
do you guys have plans well that's a
great question and I would say about
that the argument I've been making for
two weeks now is that we cannot assume
that we're going to be able to operate
with business
usual right just think about how
different the world looks today than
just seven days ago
and I think it will look fundamentally
different seven days from now than it
does today we cannot operate here under
the assumption that we can keep coming
back every week and passing bills we're
going to need to do as much as we can
while we are here because we really
don't know what happened 7 10 15 days
from now we don't and we shouldn't
pretend that we do and we should operate
under the assumption that we can't just
quickly come together again to act how
do you vote well that's a great question
and it's one of the arguments about
continuity of government that I think
needs to be examined and looked at our
government has to continue to operate
we're not going to suspend the
Constitution we're gonna I believe that
one of the things that needs to be
focused on by the leadership of the
House and the Senate is how can Congress
continue to operate when a substantial
number of their members may be in
quarantine because they or a family
member has been infected or or because
they frankly can't get here because of
travel arrangements become impossible
that's right because a dozen members of
Congress are self quarantine e'en right
now they're doing that's becoming a big
thing now thank you so much senator for
being with us good luck - thank you
everybody hang in there yep you too aq